На цих кадрах - землетрус на півночі Нідерландів, знятий камерою відеоспостереження.
Не менше 70 разів цього року в регіоні довкола Гронінгена відчувалися невеликі підземні поштовхи.
Місцевий житель Курт Фоссен пам'ятає і доволі сильний землетрус у 2012 році.
Я сидів за столом на стільці з коліщатками.
І він почав кататися туди-сюди по підлозі.
Усе трусилося. Що відбувається?
Курт Фоссен - учасник ініціативи, яка вважає видобуток природного газу причиною постійних землетрусів.
Зокрема через це газовидобувні установки в Нідерландах закриваються одна за одною.
А у 2023 році заплановано повну зупинку видобутку.
Вартість укріплення будинків задля подальшого видобутку газу занадто зросла.
І ще одна причина - газові родовища вже на 80-90% спустошені.
Таким чином Нідерланди перестають бути великим гравцем на ринку постачання газу.
Країна сама тепер має імпортувати газ. Наприклад, із сховища у нижньосаксонському Редені.
Тут під землею зберігається переважно газ із Росії. Хоча останнім часом німецькі газосховища напівпорожні, що викликає занепокоєння експертів.
Завантаження газосховищ на такому низькому рівні, як ніколи в цю пору за останні десять років.
А оскільки в останні дні грудня було холодно, а в січні також прогнозується холодна погода, запаси спустошуються доволі швидко.
Ця ситуація вже турбує всіх учасників ринку, про що сигналізують і високі ціни на газ.
Критики звинувачують "Газпром" у тому, що російський газовий концерн недопостачає газ спеціально - за погодженням із Кремлем.
На їхню думку, Москва у такий спосіб створює політичний тиск на ЄС, щоб європейці не гальмували запуск "Північного потоку-2",
який нині викликає бурхливі суперечки. Газопровід готовий до запуску, але ще не отримав дозвіл на роботу в Німеччині.
Тепер, звісно, все залежить від наших партнерів, споживачів у Європі, у ФРН.
Щойно вони ухвалять рішення про початок роботи, у Європу відразу почнуть надходити великі додаткові обсяги російського газу.
Нагадаю, це 55 мільярдів кубометрів на рік.
Володимир Путін доволі однозначно натякає європейцям: запустите "Північний потік -2" - проблеми з браком газу відразу вирішаться.
Безумовно, цей новий додатковий маршрут послужить вирішенню питання про стабілізацію цін на європейському ринку.
[…] І всі ті країни і споживачі тих країн, які споживають російський газ одразу відчують це на собі.
[…] І навіть для тієї ж України це вплине у бік зниження ціни, тому що значний обсяг газу російського походження вони беруть за цінами європейського ринку.
Насправді економічно вигіднішим і для України, і для Європи наразі було би подальше використання української ГТС, вказують окремі експерти.
Ми бачимо, що торік через українську територію прокачали трохи більше 40 мільярдів кубометрів газу,
а пропускна здатність української ГТС - десь 146 мільярдів кубометрів газу.
Тобто інфраструктура для доставки в Європу готова, діє, випробувана, надійна, жодного разу не підводила.
Але Росія схильна по цій готовій інфраструктурі, яка добре працює, газ не постачати, а примушувати Європу
погрозами підморозити користувачів енергії в Європі переходити на новий,
поки ще не відкритий маршрут "Північний потік-2". Так, це шантаж!
Тим часом ситуація загострюється. В останні дні минулого року "Газпром" перестав постачати газ
через важливий трубопровід "Ямал" на цю насосну станцію в Бранденбурзі.
Щоправда, такі газові ігри "Газпрому" з Європою можуть зрештою нашкодити йому самому.
Зараз ціни такі високі, що у нас дійсно з'являються побоювання щодо надійності постачання газу.
У недопоставках з боку "Газпрому" немає жодного сенсу, компанія руйнує імідж надійного постачальника на найближчі роки.
Принаймні у Європі на тиск "Газпрому", схоже, так швидко піддаватися не збираються
До березня, до кінця зими ми мали б протриматися - за умови,
що Росія постачатиме той мінімум, який зазвичай передбачають угоди.
Якщо ж Росія з якихось міркувань або з технічних причин не зможе чи не схоче постачати газ, то наші запаси будуть незвично малі.
[…] Утім, якщо ринок зможе реагувати на такий брак газу гнучко і зможе вибити "Газпрому" з рук його зброю,
то "Газпрому" доведеться реагувати і знову збільшити поставки, аби максимізувати вигоду.
Адже від ще більшого дефіциту він нічого не виграє.
Тим часом на тлі зростання сумнівів у надійності "Газпрому" надійшли повідомлення,
що американські танкери зі зрідженим газом змінюють курс з Азії на Європу, перед Новим роком їхня кількість зросла на третину.
Причина проста: через ціни європейський ринок стає дедалі привабливішим.